I've told you before that once you step
outside of the political debate between
the left and right about tax filing and
you mitt you may notice that I am the
top two stories today are not really
political stories they cut across
Democrats and Republicans and at the
request of the audience I'm making more
of an effort to talk about these issues
that are systemic they are not just
horse race left-right politics there is
a debate between the left and right on
taxes that exists and I'm sure at this
point you're so familiar with it that
you're probably sick of hearing it right
do we want a flat tax which is actually
regressive do we want to raise or lower
tax rates what do we want to do with
deductions all of these political
questions there's another very dirty
player in this entire thing and it's the
companies that make tax filing software
and file taxes for people so I'm
thinking of into it which makes TurboTax
and H&R Block which opens up these
offices where they file taxes for people
the left and right argue mostly about is
the tax code too complicated or do we
want to simplify it or not do we want to
change the way that we tax different
people based on their income what do we
want to do about capital gains taxes we
hear from the right about simplifying
taxes so much that we can file our taxes
on a postcard but there's a reality that
you often don't hear about which is that
even if Republicans and Democrats could
agree on exactly what should happen to
the tax code which will never happen but
imagine for a second that they could one
of the reasons that we do not see and
will not see in the foreseeable future
simplifications to how taxes work is
that the for-profit tax filing companies
lobby hard spending a ton of money to
prevent it from being easier or cheaper
to file your taxes so that people either
keep using TurboTax or keep going
to H&R Block and there are other
companies but these are kind of the big
players or they're the ones I'm
mentioning today and this Lobby is so
effective partially because they're so
well-funded partially because they are
much more
under-the-radar than for example the gun
lobby like the NRA that there is now a
bill supported by both Democrats and
Republicans which would ban the
government from offering free online tax
filing companies like Intuit and H&R
Block and others are so strong in their
lobbying of our government that our
government is effectively banning itself
from offering free online tax filing
we've been talking about this in
covering it for probably a decade
seventy percent of American taxpayers
are eligible to file file for free you
might say they file for free the hell
are you talking about David if you make
under sixty six thousand dollars a year
you are eligible to file your federal
taxes for free you are eligible for free
software however only three percent of
those who are eligible to file for free
federally actually do because these
companies are so good at upselling you
from their free product to their paid
product if you google free IRS federal
tax filing you will find a page on the
IRS website which links to all of these
different services TurboTax and others
and it says if you made under sixty six
thousand it's free to use these to file
federally now to make it clear this
doesn't include state if you want to
file there can be a cost for that if you
have a Schedule C like I get it that
it's not quite so cut and dry but again
only three percent of those eligible to
file federally for free are actually
doing it so even though the government
makes it free mandates that it be free
to file your federal taxes if you earn
under sixty six thousand dollars a year
companies like Intuit and H&R Block make
it unclear that you could file for free
they make it really clear that for
another twenty bucks you can add
deduction finder which helps you find
deductions even though most people take
the standard deduction anyway and don't
need that and to be clear this doesn't
mean anything about what should happen
with regard to the tax code from a
political perspective this is not I'm
not making a political statement about
how taxes work this bill that now is
likely to pass
sadly my four
congressman Richard Neal is signing on
to it it would straight up say the
government can't get into the activity
of providing free online tax filing
software this is our elected officials
Democrats and Republicans who love to
play politics with tax policy putting
tax filing companies which are huge
corporations above you above the average
citizen above the 70% of citizens who
could be filing federally for free very
few of whom actually do and there are
really good proposals which indicate
that with some slight modifications to
tax policy you don't have to do a flat
tax or anything that is politically
controversial you can maintain the tax
system we have some small changes could
make filing almost completely automated
for ninety percent of wage earners you
probably haven't even heard of that
given how strong the lobby is for these
tax filing companies and this is one of
the ways in which our government is
systemically reactionary or right-wing
this is codified privatization of
something that the government could
easily do and likely at a lower cost
than private industry and Democrats and
Republicans are both getting behind it
and it's disgusting if you've even heard
of the fact that this is going on I want
to hear from you I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman and the show is on Twitter at
David Pakman show if you love learning
new things you probably want to check
this out the david pakman show today is
sponsored by Skillshare and we're giving
you two entire months of free access to
Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video Skillshare is a
vibrant online learning community
offering more than 25,000 video classes
on just about anything you can think of
get better at playing an instrument
learn to use photoshop how to edit
videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting I'm still not good
but I am learning
and you can access the entire library of
fun easy-to-use online courses for free
for two months by using the link
underneath this video two months of
learning something that's totally new to
you something you want to get better at
something you already love or you can
get ahead in your career by learning new
skills that will help you at your job
I've gotten a ton out of it Pat has
taken some courses that he's found
really valuable and I think you'll love
it to get started for free
by clicking the link under this video